foreign
[Music]
and welcome to today's webinar of
proteomics signature of Nash I'm Dr Dion
Denmark the senior director of
translational medicine and clinical
development at somalagic and I'll be
your moderator for today's events
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by somalagic to learn more about
somalogic visit somalogic.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation to do so simply
type them into the ask a question box
and click Send will answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation you may also submit
any technical issues here and if you
have trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please do let us know
so I'd like to now welcome our speaker
Dr Arun sanyal director of The striat
sanyal Institute for liver disease and
metabolic Health he is also the interim
chair and professor in the division of
GI hepatology and nutrition at the BCU
Health System
Dr sanyal warm welcome thank you so much
for being here please go right ahead
thank you and good morning to everyone
it's a great pleasure for me to talk
about a topic that's very close to my
heart which is non-alcoholic fatty liver
disease and today specifically we'll
talk about the proteomic signature of
Nash
so here are my disclosures
it's a good place to start this
conversation
is to First Define what the disease
state that we're talking about actually
is
so non-alcoholic fatty liver disease
covers a spectrum of disorders
which by definition is not attributable
to the consumption of alcohol thus
non-alcoholic
the disease itself is characterized by
the accumulation of fat that produces a
disease state in the liver thus
non-alcoholic fatty liver disease
under this larger umbrella term there
are two phenotypes that are defined
histologically
one is a non-alcoholic fatty liver
where one gets a pattern of steatosis
where individual cells fill up with fat
that get washed out when we stain the
slides and they give this liver tissue a
Swiss cheese appearance as you can see
on the left and it is really not
accompanied by much else other than
occasionally a little bit of
inflammation
on the other hand there is a more
aggressive lesion called non-alcoholic
stero hepatitis or Nash for short
now in this condition you not only have
this tear ptosis but there is a Hallmark
lesion which is hepatocellular
ballooning where individual cells
balloon up as you see those big cells on
the right hand side
and they are often accompanied by
accumulation of eosinophilic inclusions
around the nucleus and that's called a
Malory tank body and this is associated
with inflammation
and it's typically in a Zone 3
distribution so together fatty liver and
Nash are part of the spectrum of
non-alcoholic fatty liver disease
now the reason to make this distinction
is because the natural course of this
disease follow in different patterns
Nash is much more likely to lead to
cirrhosis than fatty liver alone
and so once you get to cirrhosis this is
important because it is only when you
get to cirrhosis that you start getting
liver dysfunction because the liver has
a tremendous amount of Reserve
and at that stage of cirrhosis one as
with progression one gets liver
dysfunction which is often measured
clinically via parts of the Melt score
and by the development of portal
hypertension which can lead to varicel
Hemorrhage ascites encephalopathy which
are the principal liver related outcomes
in this population and the development
of heparacellular carcinoma which also
can occur in pre-serotic stages of the
disease but albeit at a much lower rate
and then all of these eventually can
culminate in mortality
so this journey towards cirrhosis and
the development of cirrhosis is
extremely important in terms of
understanding why this disease is a
public health problem
and this journey is characterized by
Progressive fibrosis so fibrosis is the
Hallmark of disease progression and when
we think about the various stages of
fibrosis the stages of fibrosis in
progressively capture not only the
amount of scar tissue which in a
trichrome stained liver biopsy slide is
shown in blue but also the distribution
of the fibrosis where as you can see it
is initially in the sinusoids and then
progressively involves both the portal
areas you can see the p in the portal
area in the second panel and the V is
the vessel and then there's fibrosis in
the middle then you form Bridges between
the central vein and the portal crack or
Central vein to Central vein and
eventually have complete circumscription
of islands of liver tissue or
regenerative nodules and that is
cirrhosis
so conceptually
when you think about a normal liver that
becomes diseased with fatty liver
disease and progresses to cirrhosis
there are two critical things to think
about
one is the concept of disease activity
and this refers to all of the injury
that is going on from the accumulation
of fat that leads to inflammation and
that is basically the driver of the
injury and the scarring that occurs and
this is captured under the microscope by
the presence of stero hepatitis versus
the fatty liver or through various
activity scores such as the nafld
activity score which is a composite of
the severity scores for cystiatosis
ballooning and inflammation the
consequence of activity is fibrosis and
is the disease stage disease stage tells
us the proximity to cirrhosis and thus
to liver-related outcomes and mortality
so in the long term our goal of course
is to reduce clinical outcomes and
improve survival but in the short term
our goal is to improve these markers of
activity based on the mechanism of
action of specific drugs and then of
course to also make sure that the
disease is not progressing and that is
reflected in Improvement in fibrosis or
stabilization of fibrosis
and we know from clinical studies that
this fibrosis progression
has very important prognostic
information and these are data from the
Nash clinical research Network which
show that the risk of hepatic
decompensation events or death from any
cause shown on the right increase
progressively from F 0 to 2 to F3 and
then from F3 to F4 so you can see really
when you get to bridging fibrosis or to
cirrhosis that's when the risk of
outcomes really dramatically increase
and this is also together often referred
to as advanced fibrosis or F3 and F4
now the other thing we have learned is
that as the liver disease progresses the
incidence of non-liver related outcomes
also increase and from this study we see
that the hazard ratio for development
print of hypertension new onset
hypertension diabetes and chronic kidney
disease in people with stage three and
four compared to Stage 0 to 2 is
significantly increased
so if you think about it in more
simplistic terms I always like to think
about the Journey of the liver in sort
of a metro rail sort of format where if
you start with Nash the progression to
cirrhosis the cirrhosis station is a
critical landmark in the natural course
of the disease now between Nash and
cirrhosis the causes of death and
outcomes are predominantly
cardiovascular cancer with rare
hepatocellular carcinomas but once you
get to that advanced fibrosis cirrhosis
stage now the lines cross and liver
related outcomes become the leading
cause of mortality followed by
cardiovascular and cancer related
outcomes so this switch occurs and so
from a liver perspective this
progression to cirrhosis is really a
critical piece and what we focus on in
drug development because that is what
prevents those liver related outcomes
so here we have shown sort of the big
picture Paradigm or what it is we're
trying to accomplish so we want to
capture people with Nash who are
particularly at risk of developing
cirrhosis and prevent that and to take
people with cirrhosis and to prevent
outcomes in those patients
so if we look at the public health
burden of disease these are data from
modeling the burden of disease from 2015
to 2030. you can see on the left hand
panel that there are about a million
people with cirrhosis currently living
in the U.S and this is expected to rise
to almost 3 million by 2030. so the
proportion of people living with
end-stage liver disease is expected to
increase two to three-fold with the
Aging of the population and continued
disease up to 2030 and we know that we
only do about 9000 transplants annually
in the US so this is not a problem that
we can transplant our way out of and
thus the need to develop effective
strategies to develop effective
strategies we need to identify who is at
greatest risk of developing these
outcomes because everybody is not at the
same risk so we think about this as
through this progression from a healthy
state to fatty liver to Nash to what we
call at-risk Nash which is presence of
Nash
activity score of 4 or higher and
fibrosis stage two or higher and these
are the people who have increased
mortality increased liver related
outcomes and eventually these are the
ones who will go on to develop cirrhosis
liver failure and death
so we want to identify those with
at-risk Nash as a very important
population for drug intervention and of
course those with cirrhosis as well
although we have not done really great
in terms of bending the needle uh with
cirrhosis yet but it could happen
now histology has been the Hallmark for
learning a lot of this knowledge and
histology has been the conventional
reference standard
and the problem of course here is that
when you want to scale this up as a
clinical tool for wide scale use
one it is invasive and can be dis
uncomfortable 10 percent patients have
significant pain and many patients don't
like to have this
it carries risks with along with the
morbidity it has a one in ten thousand
mortality rate and of course for a
diagnostic test any kind of mortality
should be a never never ever event
and in addition to that the assessment
of the liver tissue that comes out is
subject to sampling variability but also
Observer variability and the workforce
capacity to evaluate you know
potentially you know 100 million people
who could be at risk of having fat in
the liver to find out who has at-risk
Nash uh is really not an optimal Public
Health Solution
so this of course is the rationale why
we need simple non-invasive tests that
can be deployed at the point of care for
evaluation and management of Nash
okay so having set the stage as to what
disease we're talking about and what is
the problem that we are trying to solve
let's next talk a little bit about some
basic concepts in biomarker science that
will help put all of the proteomic data
that we'll eventually talk about uh in
context
so a biomarker is an objective patient
characteristic that is measured as an
indicator of either a normal or a
pathologic process or a biological
response to a therapeutic intervention
the functional definition of a
diagnostic test basically is one that
translates the complex spectrum of
disease biology into practical
actionable steps for clinicians to
improve patient outcomes
important to remember
Diagnostics make up four percent of
health care costs but informs 50 percent
of how the spend is directed
now there are many different uses of
biomarkers so when we talk about
biomarkers we must remember that
biomarker tools must be fit for purpose
based on their intended use whether it
is a diagnostic use whether it is to
assess prognosis whether it is a
predictive biomarker which tells us if
somebody is going to respond or not
respond to a certain type of treatment a
disease monitoring context of use
clinical endpoint or a surrogate
endpoint which may substitute for a
clinical endpoint based on biological
rationale prediction of clinical
endpoint and effect of treatment on the
clinical and out endpoint and outcomes
the other piece to think about as we
evaluate the utility and overall you
know where a biomarker fits in is
biology
the analytical performance how well does
the test detect the biomarker what
conditions are needed for accurate
detection the repeatability
reproducibility and then its clinical
validity and often many studies will
just show you an orac which in my view
provides information but really is an
incomplete measure of overall biomarker
performance and this from Clinical
validity we go to clinical utility and
then eventually we have to consider
benefit versus harm based on the risk of
misclassification
we also have to remember that the
prevalence of the thing that we're
looking for we're using a biomarker has
a major impact on our ability to exclude
its presence or to rule it in so when
the prevalence is extremely low you will
have very high negative predictive
values and poor positive predictive
values so just to remind you and this is
Bayesian Theory so just to remind you
that even if a test has 90 percent
sensitivity and 90 specificity which is
pretty phenomenal
if the prevalence of the disease you're
looking for is one percent
then your best predictive value that you
can get the positive predictive value
will still be in the 15 to 20 percent
range so depending on the prevalence of
and where you are using a given test
that really determines what is the most
robust type of information that you can
get and then essentially you work from
there and if you cannot get a high
positive predictive value you may need
enrichment strategies so this is just
sort of background information
so there is also a hierarchy of these
different context of views where you
start with Diagnostic and these are used
in clinical trials for inclusion
exclusion criteria then you move to
prognostic which can be used for risk
stratification leading to treatment
response etc etc
so the focus at the very bottom over
here is to identify at risk Nash this is
where we are in the field because we
have to identify the pool of patients
where we already have now generated the
data that they are at risk of Greater
increased risk of outcomes and those
particularly with Advanced fibrosis or
actually with already have cirrhosis who
even may not have clinical symptoms
because you may not get a specific
clinical symptoms until the disease
manifests with the complication of
cirrhosis
so now let's move on to the meat of the
study which is the proteomics and the
methodology that was used uh to generate
these proteomic profiles so specifically
of course we're talking today about the
Soma logic platform
so we know that each protein has a very
unique uh primary and a secondary
structure and the amino acid sequence in
these proteins are associated with
certain DNA sequences and so the core
concept here is that specific aspects of
these proteins and they're kind of
related DNA are linked through
production of aptiverse which bind with
high Affinity to specific protein
targets and are selected for the
specific shape from a very large library
of such aptimers and the Exquisite
specificity allows a scalable platform
to be established so this is already
done this is well established and this
platform has been used in multiple
settings
the workflow is as follows so you have
the substrate and you put the reagents
on top of it and it binds to the
proteins non-specific interactions can
be dissociated and cannot rebind and you
use a polyanic competitors to get all
this non-specific Binding off so
whatever is left on your target is
actually a specific protein and these
complexes and dissociated proteins are
recaptured in the remaining reagents are
then Quantified
on a chip
so this then provides us proteomic
signatures of the tissue or whatever we
are interrogating Now we move to
proteomic signatures of Nash in
appropriate context of use and we're
going to speak primarily of the
diagnostic context of use first and then
a little bit about disease monitoring
and treatment response
so how did we go about this so what I'm
going to discuss with you is a
collaborative project that we engaged in
with somalogic through the Nash clinical
research Network which is a nih-funded
research Network that I had the
opportunity to be part of and uh so this
is how we approach this this was
published recently in Journal of
hepatology so everything I'm going to
review with you is in the peer-reviewed
public domain
so the idea was to develop protein-based
current state models in Serum with
biopsy as the truth-centered so the idea
is to do a liquid biopsy
and to utilize machine learning to
develop binary classification models for
each Nas component and fibrosis remember
the nas components are steatosis
inflammation and ballooning and then to
validate these in specific independent
data sets and assess the utility also to
monitor longitudinal change during
therapy
so
while for example steatosis you can go
from grade 0 1 2 and 3. the big question
we ask ourselves is fatty liver disease
present
and when we evaluate his fatty liver
disease resolved we really make a
dichotomous position is it present or
absent so we drew the line between
negative being zero and positive being
anything more than zero which is one two
or three so we're not trying to separate
grade two versus grade 1 and that kind
of stuff here
similarly for lobular inflammation we
drew the line between grade 1 and grade
2 why because if you remember fatty
liver is fat with maybe at most zero or
a one of inflammation and the current
definition of mesh resolution in
treatment trials is that you have to
lose your ballooning and you can have
any amount of fat again that's why we
have fat Zero versus one two three and
at most zero or a one on the
inflammation so we do the line between
one and two ballooning is the Hallmark
lesion of Nash so we drew the line
between 0 and 1 so that it gives your
dichotomous readout in the end from for
decision making you know uh that but if
ballooning Goes To Zero from being
present before then you know you're
moving towards Nash resolution as long
as the other criteria are met and
similarly clinically significant
fibrosis is stage two or higher
so this was how the rationale for doing
it this way
so we had a total of about 559 patients
and they were derived from three of the
Nash crn cohorts a natural history Court
the pivins clinical trial which was
Placebo vitamin E and bioglitazone over
96 weeks and then we had the Flint trial
which was overicolic acid for Nash
and we applied plasma proteomic machine
learned models over there and so we had
an independent model training set and
from this larger pool we took a subset
of 469 patients samples for validation
and and these were again
two different validation independent
validation cohorts one was a holdout
validation cohort that was not included
in anything the other is what we called
a paired validation cohort because
remember pivence and Flint were clinical
trials so you're at Baseline and you had
end of study samples so we took half the
Baseline samples and half the end of
study samples and set them aside because
we had concomitant histology with them
so that's for lack of a better term we
call those pair validation data set and
then there was an independent holdout
validation data set now the clinical
trials also gave us an opportunity to
apply these models to longitudinal
samples from Baseline at different
points in time during the trial at uh
week 16 32 48 6480 and 96 with histology
at the two ends
so with that then let's see I lost my
pointer over here where did my
ah here we go sorry
so this then allowed us to move to the
data
so what you see at the top are the data
for State doses in the training holdout
and the paired validation group and what
you're seeing for status is grade 0 1 2
and 3 are the predicted probabilities
that somebody actually has this so we
set 0.5 as a decision threshold so
anything above that we said was yes and
if it was below then we said it didn't
meet the criteria and you're seeing the
distribution here first
steatosis at the bottom you're seeing
the data for ballooning which is a
little bit uh you know though you can
see the holdout and the paired
validation uh the data you know and
particularly for the uh scores of two uh
the data are a little bit cleaner but
there's some overlap over here
then we move on to inflammation and to
fibrosis and you can see fibrosis
particularly Advanced fibrosis and
cirrhosis very nice uh ability to
protect uh the presence of advanced
fibrosis shown in green
now this is the summary of the data so
you're seeing the sample size for the
training holdout and paired validation
you're seeing the number of cases and
then the area under the curve and the
sensitivity specificity and overall
accuracy of the test so for steatosis we
started off with you know an oracle of
1.95 and accuracy of 0.86 it did drop
off in the holder in the validation
courts but one thing I'll tell you in
the holdout validation there are only
eight patients who had no steatosis so
we didn't really have there was enough
patients without steatosis to be able to
clearly make those distinctions now if
you look at lobular inflammation It's
relatively consistent It's Not Unusual
from training to validation to have some
drop-in or Rock when you get from 0.83
down into the 0.7 range for ballooning
again you can see 0.87 but in the paired
validation you getting 0.83 holdout
validation in the 0.7 range and overall
accuracy almost in the 0.78 range
fibrosis looking very good in the 0.85
to 0.9 range so particularly for
fibrosis a Hallmark lesion of
progression uh really good overall aurox
and accuracy and then we looked post
talk at at risk because when we started
this project the concept of address
smash didn't really exist so it was by
definition of post-talk analysis where
we combined the model outputs for you
know having stero hepatitis and then
having
steatosis inflammation ballooning all
combined to meet a NS or four or higher
and then the fibrosis piece and that
gave us an orac again in the 0.85 to 0.9
range so this is very very uh
encouraging and if you look at the
accuracy again in the overall accuracy
in the 0.7 2.82 range
and these are the data for the nas
component predictions and The observed
biopsy results and we're drawing the
line over here with the biopsy stage on
the x-axis and the predicted
probabilities so you're looking at the
fibrosis piece over here and you can see
that on the right that most of this data
are about this predicted probability
line similarly for steatosis
inflammation and then also for
ballooning although there's a little bit
of a tail over here
so all of this actually looks really
encouraging because here's one platform
that's giving us a readout on multiple
aspects histologic aspects of the
disease
so when we then look at next the model
predictions for at-risk Nash versus the
histology you're seeing over here the
those the negative is with the histology
is negative and uh where the readout is
negative versus positive and you're
looking at the composite outcomes over
here in the training the holdout and the
paired validation set again you can see
that overall is beginning to separate
out it's not perfect but it looks really
good over here at being able to identify
the at-risk Nash population
so
one of the key issues in all of this so
all of this is great from a diagnostic
point of view
one of the questions that always comes
up
is are these things just random
associations or is there real biology
that is being captured here so one
caveat is anytime you measure something
in blood it is an integration of what is
happening in all the adorables and so
with that caveat then you come back and
look at this and we look at the
principle uh targets that popped out on
the analysis with steatosis what you see
here are the gene symbol the target name
the uniprot symbol the T statistic and
the p-value and you can see these all
meet false Discovery you know thresholds
and what you're seeing over here is that
there are a number of things uh from uh
iniben prostaglandin reductase insulin
like peptides some growth hormone
variants fatty acid binding protein
several of these are linked to metabolic
pathways the Syrian ire one that is
linked a little bit to uh ER stress Etc
so number of these actually do show
uh are linked to Pathways that are known
to be connected to metabolic pathways
that are involved in lipid metabolism
similar while some actually are novel
discoveries as well
now if you look at lobular inflammation
again you are seeing you know number of
things such as the immunoglobulin uh
receptors over here adiponectin which
has been linked also to uh the
inflammatory response and we didn't see
it in steatosis over here as one of the
top hits but it came out in the
inflammation piece peptide YY other
things over here serum Associated
amyloid so a number of these are known
to be associated with inflammation
chemokines
Etc and then there are couple that are
also uh new findings what is then you go
to ballooning over here I draw your
attention again to number of these
parameters of these the akr1 B10 is very
interesting to me and you can see that
the p-value is 2.2 times 10 power minus
16. and this is part of the Aldo keto
reductase family and really has
understudied Target and this we
published a paper on the transcriptomic
profile of Nash and this came out
strongly to be related both to
ballooning and disease progression in
that Trend paper on Nash transcriptomics
since then the Newcastle group published
a paper where this again popped out as a
marker associated with more aggressive
disease and now we're seeing it as part
of the proteomic signature in the blood
linked to hepatocellular ballooning so
you know there's biology interspersed
through all of these but we're also
learning about new Pathways and trying
to figure out how these all play in once
again we published long time ago that
lipo oxygenasis and prostaglandin
biology is important in Nash and here
again you're seeing a number of signals
related to the prostaglandin activities
and then of course with fibrosis many of
these are actually linked to Matrix and
and some of these linked also to
inflammatory Cascades and there's a
growing body of literature on the
potential role of the complement in this
process so there's a lot of biology that
is also in here and integrated
throughout and these of course you know
are going to provide a platform and
substrate for specific hypothesis-driven
studies moving forward and we're going
to learn a lot from this type of
proteomic approaches to really
understand the factors that are
critically important in disease
progression and in development of more
aggressive disease phenotypes now
talking of disease progression
we've sort of talked about the
diagnostic piece so now let's move on to
the disease monitoring and treatment
response aspects of this
so first we looked at the pivence trial
and this is just to refresh your memory
of the Pivens trial we looked at Vitamin
E and bioglitazone and compared it to
Placebo because there were two primary
comparisons the p-value was set at .025
and you can see over here the proportion
of people who improved steatosis is
significantly greater than Placebo for
both vitamin E and biogladison
similarly
and these are the P values over here
similarly when you look at the
Improvement in ballooning you see the
proportion of people who had improved
ballooning significantly greater in both
vitamin E and in bioglota zone compared
to placebo
and when you look at fibrosis that
there's a higher proportion of people
numerically in both bioglitazone and
vitamin E compared to Placebo but these
did not reach statistical significance
and part of it is this study was not
really powered to detect this effect
size so for this effect size if we had a
three times larger sample size this
would have reached a statistical power
so if you think of the size of the
current many of the current uh phase
three trials that are going on as
opposed to the pivots trial with this
effect size you would have actually
started seeing some statistical
significance as well so keeping this at
the back of your mind now we move on to
look at the proteomics signatures that
we potentially saw in these patients So
based on our models where we again set
the Threshold at 0.5 we are reading a
probability score that the model has
changed from you know uh before to uh at
the different points at which we
measured these uh tests that they have
fallen below those thresholds for
skipped statuses and you're seeing this
response in steatosis uh in BIO glitter
Zone shown in the dark blue vitamin E
little bit less and the placebo is
relatively flat also indicating that the
proteomic signatures are relatively
specific so they were able to cleanly
separate out the placebo on from these
treatment arms similarly when you look
at ballooning on the right their Placebo
remains relatively flat and you're
seeing a very nice reduction uh in the
ballooning shown on the right we see an
improvement in inflammation and you're
even capturing the small differences
that we saw histologically in fibrosis
and remember that these signatures the
proteomics are priori independent gently
predicted this without really it was not
modeled the histologic outcome was not
part of the model we that was the
validation piece so the model predicted
whether fibrosis is getting better model
predicted if inflammation is getting
better model predictive status is
getting better and then we checked to
see whether indeed it got better or not
and so this is what you see that's why I
showed you the histology data just up
front just to set the stage and as a
frame setting uh concept
so now if you move on to the Flint study
what we see over here are the primary is
the histological outcomes so you're
seeing the primary endpoint which was a
Nas Improvement of two points or more
and the proportion of people who met it
blue is OCA uh the open bar is Placebo
you're seeing Improvement in steatosis
lobular inflammation ballooning fibrosis
and then Nash resolution and then Auto
inflammation over here
so here you can see the changes in
statuses are more modest and remember
though although histologically we did
see Improvement in steatosis in the
regenerate trial this did not
necessarily translate into its big
difference uh so we it the data are what
they are but you do see a modest
improvement with ballooning over here
looks like the ballooning the oci group
had a little more ballooning to start
with but they did show this Improvement
in ballooning uh compared to the placebo
which was relatively flat similarly you
can see a nice Improvement in
inflammation and then with fibrosis also
you can see at beginning the fibrosis
cores were higher and they trended down
over time so that at week 72 when the
biopsy was done the fibrosis it looked
was lower compared to the placebo arm so
there is some overlap over here but
basically the trend lines all look
they're moving in the right direction in
terms of the ability of the proteomic
model to predict the histologic response
now so that what we've shown you here is
that first that the placebo response
arms remain relatively flat so in a
blinded manner the uh or mass manner the
model was able to identify that these
These are the placebo armor patients and
they didn't really change that much uh
and were relatively flat and tracked the
histology the second is across three
different mechanisms of action so you
have pile of glutathione you have
vitamin E and then you have OCA that in
general these are tracking the
histologic response in these patients at
an individual patient level uh
concordant where in a patient level
concordant way which is extremely
encouraging and I think this is really
the first time we have longitudinal data
using a blood-based biomarker that is
actually
tracking the outcomes with the key
histologic features of Nash uh in the
setting of a well constructed rigorously
done Clinic set of clinical not just one
but a set of clinical trials now talking
of clinical trials those were all
studies that were done through the Nash
crn which is a network of eight academic
centers with a very deep interest in
Nash and a pathology committee which has
eight members and they read histology in
a very specific way uh with a very
defined protocol so maybe in an
otherwise other setting those data might
not be quite as translatable so these
are data from a recently published uh or
presented Falcon trial so this is a post
talk analysis uh from the Falcon trial
so I'll to remind you again the Falcon
trial looked at fgf21 Peg Bell Furman
and this is in a patients with bridging
fibrosis and Falcon 2 was in cirrhosis
and essentially the idea here in this
post-talk analysis was to see whether
all the different biomarkers and the
histology
what was the level of concordance
between these and so what you see over
here at the top is the primary
histologic endpoint which is fibrosis
regression then you have the ishac
fibrosis stage which is modified for
Nash then you have Nas lobular
inflammation ballooning Nas overall
liver stiffness with MRE elf score Pro
C3 verpo pc3x LDL then you have the Soma
signals and then a whole bunch you can
see astlt and astitosis fib4 Etc so
group one are people who are who are
these are people who are non-responders
so non-responders are in Black
responders are in yellow so if you look
all the way to the right now here are
people of people who predominantly are
responders where everything got better
and you can see over here that the Soma
signals actually picking these out and
on the very left side picking the
non-responders out very well so I have
arrows to point out at the proteomic
model which is the Nash theodosis you
have the inflammation your fibrosis your
ballooning and so over here if you look
on the left you're looking at all this
dark blue and black so it's picking this
up very nicely at the top over here on
the left is the histology that matches
this and if you go to the right if you
look at people who are completely
histologic responders over here you can
see the Soma signals picking it up there
is a population in the middle which is
noisy and there needs to be more
refinement here but again it shows that
the overall performance is actually very
very encouraging and I think this is
actually an important step forward in
the field to try and uh better Define
non-invasive methods of evaluating
histologic response
so to wrap up in summary
proteomic analysis of serum can identify
a signature for key features of Nash
that is theodosis lobular inflammation
hepatocellular ballooning and fibrosis
these are related to biological pathways
linked to Nash and also several novel
targets and Pathways were identified
in independent validation cohort the
signatures could be reproduced
these measures were also sensitive to
change and recapitulated many of the
histologic changes seen in Placebo and
treatment arms of several clinical
trials
these proteomics signatures carry the
potential to serve as important
Diagnostic and disease monitoring slash
treatment response assessment tools
while much work Still Remains to be done
these are very important steps in the
field and foundational for the future
work that remains to be done so with
that I will conclude and thank you very
much for listening to me and I look
forward to your questions
thank you
thank you for this excellent
presentation we will now start the live
q a portion of the webinar if you have a
question you'd like to ask these
students now just click on the ask
box located on the far left of your
screen will answer as many of your
questions as we have time for today
so let's get started looks like we have
a question about Pro C3 was this
detected anywhere in the data set
no we did not measure pro C3 in this
data set to my knowledge but maybe
somebody from somalogic can answer but
to my knowledge it was not done the list
of uh the proteins that were measured
yeah I don't know off the top of my head
either but we can certainly delve into
that a little bit more if it's not on
the platform we can share some more
information about what we may know about
anything related do you have any
thoughts Dr sanyal about
um what was seen in the proteomic signal
sort of on a pathway level with Pro C3
or anything that might indicate that
there was some Association
so I want to remind people that
Pro C3
is a collagen fragment so when you are
actually having fibrogenesis you have
you know during both fibrogenesis and
fibrolysis
you you have uh while the collagen is
being made and broken down small pieces
of collagen break off and can go into
circulation and pro C3 specifically was
developed as something which is a marker
of the fibrogenesis uh activity and uh
so it is not a biological pathway itself
it's a fragment indicative of fibrogenic
drive if you will and so in the in this
particular study uh
if I can go over here and bring this
back up over here some of the things
that we saw were linked to add you know
these are all uh proteins that are
linked to connecting inflammation and
Matrix you have collecting you have
neurofacin you have complement uh FC
receptor like protein vegf which has
been linked to uh you know
fibrogenic Drive there's a pro collagen
dioxygenase 3 which is probably the
closest one to the collagen synthetic
pathway itself then there are protein
signatures linked to wind that were in
here so these are the ones that actually
popped out over here in this analysis
we do see Pro collagen uh endopeptidase
enhancer to in the lobular inflammation
uh you know peace and the atoms like
protein 2 is one of the few that are
common between ballooning and fibrosis
so I think that's another one that is
worthy of keeping an eye on because this
may be another uh you know biomarker
that links the activity to the fibrosis
readout
yeah terrific thank you related to that
there's a question specifically about
macrophage markers where any of these
detected
so there were a number of biomarkers
detected but in terms of using them as a
diagnostic signature uh you know they
did not make it into the cut at the very
top you know these P values for false
Discovery Etc so you know as you go down
this list you know uh
the P values and the false Discovery
rates tend to change so we sort of
initially set this relatively you know
conservatively but there are the full
list is actually provided with the
manuscripts and uh one can look at that
and there were things in there but they
form a diagnostic signature point of
view they did not you know rise to the
top of the list uh to support its use as
a diagnostic uh you know uh panel
does that make sense yeah definitely
thank you very much it's important to
make those distinctions yeah very
important to remember that the biology
the inflammatory process is very complex
and noisy with a lot of different
Pathways and signals involved so what we
were trying to do over here which is a
biomarker exercise for Diagnostics is to
take the signals that Rose above the
noise with enough Fidelity to Warrant
trying to create a panel around it
perfect great thank you uh there is a
comment great presentation thanks very
much what is the most translatable
pre-clinical animal model and the most
reliable biomarkers of such models of
Nash and there's a follow-up too but
we'll start there
it's a loaded question
so you know pre-clinical models are only
as good as the question that you are
trying to ask so if you want to learn a
specific pathway you know there are
various uh over expression or loss of
function models that are available there
are also now a number of ipsc derived
models there are small in vitro models
where you take hepatocytes uh backer
Pages uh endothelials not endothelial
cells macrophages and stellate cells and
put them into Chambers with flow like
the Hemo share model there are other
organoid models that have been developed
then there are Mouse models and probably
the ones that are closest are the diet
induced to be City models which
replicate the systemic milieu in which
the fatty liver disease develops the
models where the liver I can tell you
which models are not very good in my
opinion you know models like the McD
model where you can get a very nice
liver phenotype but the overall systemic
milieu where the animals don't gain
weight you don't develop the systemic
inflammatory and Insulin resistant State
and obesity and adiposity that probably
is not a great model
models that are dependent on knocking a
specific Gene in or out models that are
dependent on giving poisons like carbon
tetrachloride to induce fibrosis that no
human being will ever see are less
translatable the closer the model comes
to reflecting the conditions in which
the human disease develops uh you know
and there have been a number of recent
Publications sort of looking at all
these different parameters so I would
recommend that you look up uh there are
there's a paper in the last couple of
years uh looking at I'm blocking on the
first author but it was in hepatology I
believe looking at all the available
models and sort of comparing them and so
in general the diet induced obesity type
models came out on top it's important to
also remember that there are diet
induced models which use very high
levels of cholesterol and uh that are
again creates another layer of
difficulty in Translation to humans uh
although in general they reflect sort of
the same disease phenotype so that's the
pre-clinical model question there was a
second follow-up question wasn't there
yeah
no no that was terrific uh the second
part of the question was is there any
scope for new biomarker identification
and animal models to accurately predict
the disease progression in addition to
the history of pathology findings oh
absolutely related absolutely the short
answer is yes and the long answer of
course can be very complicated but I
think if you pick models that develop
that meet the systemic milieu the
insulin resistance related parameters
who develop the histology and the
fibrosis progression to Advanced
fibrosis or lucerosis and those that
have a transcriptomic profile that is
strongly concordant with human disease
at each stage because even within the
same patient the transcriptome changes
as the disease moves from one stage to
the next you know if you get that type
of model those provide very powerful
opportunities for additional uh you know
novel biomarker Discovery
by no means have we solved the biomarker
issue yet I think there's lots of room
for more work and novel biomarkers
yeah excellent thank you uh just one
more specifically related to
pre-clinical models is fructose-induced
Nash and zebrafish as a model to test
data hepatitis is how how robust is that
as a model
it's a high throughput system to see
whether you get steatosis and the key
and I have not seen that data and that's
just me that doesn't mean it doesn't
exist is really a strong
concordance between the zebrafish models
and the human transcriptome and fibrosis
progression signals getting fat to
accumulate is pretty easy you know
across a variety of mechanisms
showing actually that it leads to injury
and fibrosis and that it matches the
human disease progression those are
critical elements in terms of maximizing
the likelihood of translatability even
with all these caveats there's always a
gap between pre-clinical models and
humans our approach therefore has always
been instead of moving from pre-clinical
to Human
just to actually start with the human
Define the disease State and then try to
find the preclinical models to get them
as close to the human and then to do
back translation to understand how
specific Pathways and other things
behave in the pre-clinical models
because you can do things in those
models that you cannot for obvious
reasons do in humans
yeah yeah that makes great sense thank
you so moving now to a little bit about
the signatures would these signatures be
relevant for multiple different
mechanisms uh targeting Nash to measure
treatment response so we have got data I
can only respond to what we have data on
so we've got data on vitamin E bio
glitter Zone and OCA and these tend to
track uh in these populations uh whether
they will apply to other mechanisms of
action will need to generate the data to
show typically you know if you look at
how biomarkers were developed for
example hemoglobin A1C for diabetes you
know once you have data across multiple
mechanisms of action widely disparate
mechanisms of action I think uh then
you're getting closer to having
something that meets the biological uh
aspects of is one of the check boxes for
on the develop Pathway to developing a
surrogate endpoint but I think this is
very encouraging because to my knowledge
we have not had a biomarker panel to
date that across multiple mechanisms of
action can separate the placebo
responses from the drug responses
yeah yeah it is very exciting along
those lines can you comment a little bit
about the populations used in these
models and the prevalence in different
ethnicities of Nash and how
generalizable these models may be
I don't think we have the data to make
large popular you know this was 560
patients from the Nash crn so the Nash
crn is uh a uh NIH funded Consortium in
academic centers with all the
ascertainment bias that goes on in those
kind of centers it is predominantly a
Caucasian cohort very small number of
Hispanics and even smaller number of
African-Americans and Nations so there
is still an unmet need to test the
robustness of the diagnostic utility of
these and the disease monitoring utility
in larger cohorts I believe in litmus
this is being looked at but again I
remind you that litmus is a Western
European Consortium so again you're
getting more data with the predominantly
Caucasian cohort so there is certainly
room to look at larger cohorts and in
greater populations in a particularly
Hispanics because uh
they of are at risk of more aggressive
disease uh they do tend to get they have
the pain underlying pnpl3 mutation they
have other things going on that really
put them at risk of getting more
diabetes more liver disease more
outcomes uh and so that's a huge unmet
need I think that's still present and
African-Americans even though the
popular the prevalence is very low but
there are people Africa it's a common
misconception that African-Americans
cannot get the disease their their risk
is low but we have seen African
Americans also uh who have significant
Nash and how these models perform on
those in large enough numbers of African
Americans also remains a little bit of
an open question
yeah thank you so so important to pursue
that work uh how do the individual
component scores correlate to comparable
clinical assessments like inflammation
score versus Alt or steatosis score
versus fat fraction on MRI pdff
so we don't have a lot of PDF of data
remember a lot of these MRI tools were
developed after Pivens and these are all
based on Sample sets that are a little
uh you know uh that uh that were sort of
predated before we got going with a lot
of mr-based measures Etc so you cannot
answer that question uh even the
fibroscans came much later into the
story compared to when we started with
this sample sets this has been a long
journey by the way and uh just to remind
everybody the initial uh you know all of
this really started
actually quite a few years ago so this
has been a long time coming
so everybody thinks you can just go get
samples and off you go and in three
months have the results this has been
quite a process to get to this point uh
we don't have that data unfortunately
and again would love to sort of
obviously that's a very relevant
question and we need to look at that now
alt is very interesting so
what we are measuring here are the
aptomers the protein itself whereas the
assay that we measure clinically is a
functional assay where you take the
serum and you have a substrate for alt
and you get a color signal and the rate
of color development determines sort of
is rid of a spectrophotometer and you
know the uh and there is a standard
curve from which the astlt values are
estimated so we did not actually see a
correlation with asdlt but the measures
are completely the way they measured
it's a little bit apples and oranges
because what you're what you're hearing
measuring here is the presence of the
protein and not it's necessarily its
functionality so uh the uh so it doesn't
really exactly correlate but we did not
see and it's in the manuscript as well
that we did not see this correlation
with AST and LT
so we have time for one more question
we've we really would like
for your research and proteomics
applications in these areas of high
clinical unmet need and what do you
think is needed to help establish these
models of screening tools for clinical
research and Diagnostics
I think we need a larger and a more
diverse Diagnostics to test this in a
larger and a more diverse population for
Diagnostic purposes
we need more data on prognostic and then
hopefully some of the clinical trials
that are including these panels for
evaluating treatment response will give
us additional data on disease monitoring
together I think these will help move
the proteomics platform along you know
to answer the key unmet needs within the
biomarker space
from my personal research you know we're
doing a lot of work with a number of
biomarkers so we also have ongoing
studies with fibrosis biomarkers such as
the adapt score which is modified from
Pro C3 with niss4 and Now list two and
then with else score so we've got a lot
of we have a very deep interest across a
broad range of biomarkers and we are
particularly now that we have Imaging
tools as well through the Nimble
Consortium uh you know we hope that in
stage two of nimble we will be able to
look simultaneously with ultrasound
based tools mr-based tools and
circulating biomarkers to address some
obesity unmetic context of use
yeah excellent we really look forward to
that thank you so much again for your
time today Dr Samuel and you're really
critical and exciting research we'd also
like to thank lab roots and the sponsor
Soma Logic for underwriting today's
educational webcast before we go I would
like to thank the audience for joining
us today and for their very interesting
questions questions we did not have time
for today and those submitted during the
on-demand period will be addressed by
the speaker via the contact information
you provided at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
Roots will alert you via email when it's
available for replay we encourage you to
share that email with your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
until next time have a great day